[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant ses 70 ans il y à lui la paix et
la sécurité
nous parlons de la possibilité réelle
d'une guerre en europe attend pouvoir
éviter la guerre en ukraine alors que la
tension reste vive sur le terrain les
efforts diplomatiques se poursuivent
emmanuel macron et vladimir poutine ont
fait le point au téléphone sur la crise
pendant près de deux heures tous deux
disent vouloir aboutir rapidement un
cessez le feu dans l'est de l'ukraine
comme l'indiquent le communiqué publié
par l'elysée à l'issue de cet entretien
les deux chefs d'état ont pris des
engagements fermes de mener toutes les
actions utiles pour éviter l' escalade
réduire les risques et préserver la paix
quelles que soient ses intentions il
s'est placé au fur et à mesure dans une
position qui a abaissé sa crédibilité
d'ailleurs poutine a dit une fois d'une
manière assez déplaisante je trouve que
les français n'étaient pas dans
l'équation je pense que la france ne
peut avoir véritablement une voix qui
porte que si elle apparaît comme la
france et comme personne d'autre pas
comme le porte-voix de l'otan pas comme
le porte-voix de l'union européenne nous
sommes vus par les russes comme les
petits télégraphistes de washington qui
veut aller ensuite en référé aux patrons
qui est byetone marisol touraine
ministre de la santé de françois
hollande estime qu emmanuel macron est
aujourd'hui le seul vote utile est
responsable notamment face à l'extrême
droite même revirement d'elisabeth
guigou ex garde des sceaux c'est quoi
c'est la gauche est en train de
s'éclater remet bien c'est à vue marisol
touraine elisabeth guigou se rallier à
emmanuel macron sont à des remaniements
plus qu'autre chose le vote quand on est
de gauche quand on a des valeurs
sociales qui sont ancrées au corps et
quand on veut qu'elle soit portée
pendant cinq ans dans notre pays le vote
mélenchon c'est pas le vote utile c'est
le vote utile vous vous dites vote
efficace quelle est la différence
d'abord commencé lundi après que vous en
êtes à faire des observations fine tout
le monde parle de vote aussi vous avez
remarqué nous n'avons pas les
parrainages c'est une situation qui
démocratiquement est terrifiante les
terrifiantes je n'ai jamais été aussi
inquiète s'il n'arrive pas à bord de
parrainage c'est qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
convaincre les élus locaux
de les parrainer ça veut dire qu'il ne
faut pas envie aux élus locaux qui ne
leur disent moi je ne suis pas prêt à
vous faire confiance beaucoup de
candidats sont dans la même situation
que moi c'est à dire que le réservoir
s'est totalement asséché pourquoi parce
que les maires depuis des décennies 10
ce système ne fonctionne pas et que
personne au pouvoir n'a voulu le changer
je n'ai aucune certitude
c'est très dur
nous nous sommes tous mis à téléphoner
on passe des heures au lit il faudrait
savoir quand même le le temps pris par
sept par cette occupation mais pas
suffisamment travaillé pour les obtenir
comment est ce que vous faites matériaux
et de vous alors que vous n'avez jamais
cherché un parrainage de votre vie mais
évidemment les candidats d'action
positive quoi dé quoi vous croyez qu'on
est des amateurs non je vous dis juste
que nathalie arthaud elle a réussi à les
avoir elle les charges de mai dernier
vous ne savez combien at war et dans sa
précieuse chère madame c'est un peu oui
mais vous êtes assuré que non ici le 4
mars eric jeu vous pourrez sonia
l'association je me suis assurée donc
envisager cette fois ci ils voulaient me
parrainer et je reçu deux témoignages de
mères qui vomit presque les larmes aux
yeux ça va pleurer mais tellement il
voulait que je sois candidat à tout prix
nous avions plus de 600 promesses de
parrainages donc il ya à trouver une
explication entre le fait d'avoir autant
de promesses de parrainages et d'avoir
aussi peu de parrainage concrétiser le
minimum qu'il faudrait faire c'est les
rendre anonymes ces parrainages pour que
les mères ne n'ai pas le sentiment de
devoir ensuite justifié ce qui sera un
soutien politique à reine elizabeth ii
d'angleterre a été testée positive au
qu'ovide 19 elle souffre de symptômes
similaires à ceux d'un rhume